[Music]
hi this is mario aquino i'm one of the
organizers for the strange loop
conference
and this is another episode of strange
loop chats with me today is paula guerin
she is an engineer at cisco in the
threat grid group
and we're going to be talking today
about an open source database that paula
maintains it's called asami
before i get to that i'd like to mention
that strange loop this year is going to
start on thursday september 30th which
is going to be our workshop day
and the conference proper is going to
start on friday october 1st and run two
days
the 1st and 2nd of october if you'd like
to find out more
you can visit thestrangeloop.com for
details about
tickets and the schedule so with that
out of the way
let me introduce paula paula thank you
for
sitting with me for this interview
welcome
thanks mario so i wanted to talk to you
today
about asami what can you tell me about
asami what is it
it's a graph database and it started
life
as a in memory graph database but
recently we've developed it into
something which also
stores persistently on disk and looking
at different types of provisioning for
being able to store it in lots of
different ways and locations as well but
yeah it's a
graph database written entirely in
closure and it
is there to provide graph services for
closure developers who want to use data
in that way
so can you describe what exactly is a
graph database
the graph database represents graph data
where a graph
in the mathematical sense is essentially
like a network
it looks like a whole series of nodes
with lines
uh connecting so we typically think of
these things as each node
each start representing some kind of
resource and then the line in between
will have a label and it will be
typically in a direction so if i have a
resource
which represents a person i can have
lines in which go off to the different
attributes of the person like their name
their address
and things like that and i can also have
lines which connect
that person's node to nodes which
represent other people either as friends
or their manager
or neighbors then we can have nodes
which represent
companies or cities or anything at all
really
and so it's a very flexible arrangement
for data
and it provides this really consistent
way of looking at any kind of data at
all
so it's a database that allows you to
establish relationships between entities
that you store in it and it's written in
closure
is it a database that also works in
closure script originally i wrote it as
closure and then i was asked can you
move it up into the browser so we did
our principal use for it at
cisco at the moment is in the browser
and it's
operating as a memory model for an
important product that we've got which
has a lot of deployment
internationally now but it also works on
a machine
running on the jvm and it's in that
state at the moment that we've been
working
a lot with the persistence model for how
this can be stored
effectively so the name asami
can you tell me what is that sort of an
internal joke
um five years ago we
uh started with this project which was
the
uh internet resource orchestration hub
ira
or uncle iro was a character in the tv
series
avatar the last fair bender and our
manager at the time
really enjoyed that show and he started
naming all these all of these projects
after
avatar character this i think ira
running in the cloud was called
tenzin which is from the avatar spin-off
well asami
is a character from cora as well
originally i
had written a rules engine which
used asani and that engine was called
naga
again another character from the same tv
show
so what would you say distinguishes
asami from
other graph databases well
every graph database has its own pros
and cons i mean originally asami was
simply
an in-memory model for naga because we
wanted something
which where we wouldn't need an external
dependency
i was building it around daytonic and
because we were going to be doing this
thing in-house i was asked well
could you maybe do something that
doesn't involve a commercial system with
that way this whole thing could be open
source and
i if i had thought i was going to build
an entire graph database i'd have said
none
we weren't aware of data script at that
point i built the basic functionality
that was required because that's all we
needed
but over time as naga needed to do more
things with rules
we introduced more and more features and
finally i realized that
this storage system had gained a life of
its own
and we broke it out into its own project
and now it's become
dominant work for me where the the whole
query engine the query language
everything's been expanding and you know
from that point it then
i was asked to move it into the browser
and so it became a cross-platform
project between
jvm and enclosure script in the browser
so yeah running our own project that way
did give us the flexibility to make that
move
and it's also given us the opportunity
to introduce new features as we wanted
them
things like aggregates which you know
daytonic already had
but also things like graph analytics so
we can do
queries on transitive attributes or we
can find
subgrants where if you've got two
distinct
disconnected graphs we can identify
those
and you know different sorts of graph
algorithms like this
are all things we've been able to
implement internally so that they're
really
optimized for the data structures you
mentioned that asami has
querying capability you know you can't
really have a
database without a querying capability
what would you say inspired the way that
the querying works in asami
two things um firstly daytona
so daytonic has specified a graph
querying language
which is written in using the data
structures that make up closure itself
so essentially eden and
that's been really useful to leverage
because we can read it for free we don't
have to worry about parsing
but the other thing that it's based on
is sparkle so
20 years ago i was a lead architect
on another graph database called moldara
and that was written entirely for the
jvm
back then we developed our own query
language and
over time it became clear that idf data
required its own
query language a standard and so a
committee was formed which was the
spargle committee
i wasn't on that one i contributed to it
but then
some years later as new features were
required the second cycle committee was
put together and i was on that i was one
of the editors for
the documents so there's a whole lot of
semantics in sparkle which
differ a little bit from daytonic
and because of some of the architectural
decisions that we've made in asami it
made much more sense to go
often with the sparkle semantics over
the the daytona genetics
so the syntax is is some kind of a
a union between atomic query language
and
sparkle semantics mostly in the edge
cases
in most queries you're going to find
that you can copy paste something from
daytona or datascript and just use it on
asami and it'll just work
but there are a few uh a few things
where you're going to find
like doing a not operation or certain
kinds of unions
where the edge cases lean more towards
the sparkle
interpretation of the world rather than
daytona
so what would you say is sort of uh
an ideal use case for for asami where
does it really shine
when you've got a lot of disparate data
so a lot of data that you're getting
from different places where you want to
find linkages between the data where you
want to
take data which may have come from
tables but when you put it together you
would
otherwise require dozens and dozens of
tables with lots of foreign joins and
things like that
if it were in the relational world when
you're bringing a lot of
data together like that then graph
databases in general are very useful
that way asami
has been designed internally to be
optimized around querying
it's optimized around querying but you
know at the expense of taking a little
longer to load data around
so if you're going to be doing as
someone mentioned yesterday
30 transactions a second then
assam is going to be slower than but if
you're only
you know if you're loading your data up
once or every few minutes
then and querying it a lot and analyzing
it a lot then assam is really going to
show
and you know assignment can still handle
a lot of transactions
but there are other systems which are
going to be optimized more around that
and yet they won't necessarily answer
queries as quickly
you're actively maintaining asami what
is it that you're
sort of focusing on right now in terms
of the feature set that you're trying to
bring to it
i'm focusing on what my colleagues at
work say they need
so when someone says like can i do this
or doesn't that
you know does this work the way i think
it should then
that's my main priority but when people
aren't asking me for that i've been
working
on storage with just coming up to
a 2.0 release which is where the the
durable storage they're not entirely
confined to memory anymore
is finally going to be released there's
more architecture to happen there there
are
certain elements of it which i'm really
happy with and other things which i know
could uh use more effective data
structures
but it works really well at the moment
and i'm looking forward to just getting
that out the door
and then we've got more more layers of
indexing
and and features that we want to have
there you know
there's trade-offs at every level but
looking at and introducing some of these
new features
to meet the the requirements that my
colleagues have frankly to
you know to speed up certain things and
to make data available easily
in in some ways where it may not be so
easy
to get to it at the moment so in terms
of
durable storage what is the sort of goal
for being able to to persist
the database i guess in in its in the
in a format that has already some some
amount of entity data
in it is it for replication is it for
quick loading like a database that
already
you know contains so everything's
immutable internally
and i have a whole lot of documentation
around this
on the on the project website and it you
know internally
the uh closure itself uses these kinds
of data structures
the last database i was working on
moldara it also used
that kind of data structure and because
we have a whole lot of immutable data
structures
so things which never change we only add
to the storage
this means that replication is really
quite easy
we can just take things knowing that
they're never going to change again
we can then spread it across the cluster
because
again we know that once something's been
written it never changes
and this gives us a whole lot of you
know advantages almost for free
one of the one of the things which you
know when daytonic came out it seemed
relevant
like a revelation was that
you could go back in time and look at
how things used to be ironically mulgara
always had that kind of data structure
but
we built it 20 years ago when disc
wasn't as cheap as it is now
and consequently we needed to clean up
any data that was old that we weren't
using anymore and
you know for performance reasons over
time i eventually ripped that
that code out because all that
bookkeeping and cleanliness was
you know had a cost for the database and
so i was just leaving these things
hanging around
and then when daytonic came out and we
were shown that we had this rich history
of what all the data would look like
getting to this point
i realized at that point that mulgara
already had that but it just hadn't
exposed it to the user asami has that
now
and it's been inspired by my by
muldering structures
i've modernized them i updated things
over the years as i came up with better
ideas as to how these things should be
built
and yeah so a number of the features
which
which daytonic has which make it like
very different to
other sorts of databases before uh are
also present
in asani and you know i kind of
while i'm not aiming to do exactly the
same sorts of things as
daytonic at the same time it has led me
to certain features thinking you know i
kind of like that i'd like to have my
have that in my system as well and sure
enough people
you know for the things i haven't
finished doing people come to me and say
when do we get this feature so i know
that it's wanted community wise
there are i guess groups outside of
cisco
that are either using or experimenting
with asami
so a friend of mine started a channel on
the closure in slack
and a number of people have been joining
it i've seen people saying that they
assessing the sami for their workplace
i've had feedback i've had
full requests to you know to create new
features
or to expand on things and so
there seems to be a lot of interest
about what i'm doing which is
really quite nice and you know i want to
be responsive to
the people who are using it as well yeah
i mean this was kind of a hobby of mine
that i was doing on the side and i
showed my manager years ago and he said
this looks great do it for work
and you know so i'm i'm in a really
privileged position that i get to do
something which i was finding
interesting
for my job and you know i i want to be
as responsive to people as i can be so
that i get to keep doing this job so
for folks interested in checking out
asami for themselves
where should they go to github it's
under threat grid asami it's an open
source project all the documentation's
online
i do work hard to try to make sure that
everything is really well documented
a lot of times people ask me for how
things are working and i'm able to point
them at docs
and that's really paid for itself so
hopefully if you need to find things
then you can go there otherwise
you can always go to the clojurian slack
and look for asami
if you ask questions i do try to be as
responsive
as i can be all right well
paula i want to thank you for sitting
down for this
strange loop chat and for folks who are
watching if you would like to find out
more about asami there will be
links when this video is posted to where
you can read about it
on github well paula thanks again it's
been great talking to you
you're welcome thanks maureen
[Music]
you